Đóng châu đồng hành hoa í, để học í dựa thành phố chiming khám vệ lưu động miếp,
mà đầu hành trình chẳng xong xuống khỏe ngưu dân tủng sâu của ra.
Bình đi với sử mệ tìm một Việt Nam khỏe mạnh cùng miếm tên xấu sắc sàng bối hợi điều dân đáng
tức cật ít tế một cách câu bằng, lưu sống khỏe mạnh và hành phúc,
lóng châu đồng hành cùng để học í dựa thành phố chiming trình khai tổ chức khám vệ lưu động và cấp thu bình thí.
Đây là hóa động tưu việc trong sự án lắm xấu sẻ chia,
mà mình cơ hội tức cật ít tế, công bằng,
bó vình là toả tức tình vì một xấu hội quẩy mạnh, nhưng đang gặp bình bước.
Bơ qua, tại xá quẩy hư, vệ đất lòng, tính đất nông,
hành trình lòng xấu sẻ chia, vì một Việt Nam quẩy mạnh hơn đã chiến thức được lưu khởi động.
Thế đó, lóng châu phố hợi cùng khoa í,
để học í dựa thành phố chiming tổ chức khám vưu động và cấp thu bình thí cho vệ dân ở dựa tình thành trên tận quốc.
Thông qua dựa này, lóng châu mà muốn tạo cơ hội cho cộng đồng,
đặc biệt là người dân bùng xấu, bùng xa, đưa trang xóc ít để phòng bệnh và tâm xóa bị tự giống.
Hành trình xức khỏe mấy trang xóc bà đưa tự chính,
chế, phù nước, người lắng tủy vào người bệnh mạnh tình.
Dự án đã thịt thương khám và trang xóc xuất khỏe chức kết cho hơn mấy người.
Đông gời chuyên thông đem gào nhận thức xấu hâm hiểu về việc chủ động tâm xóa bị giống,
phòng bệnh và tình thủ đuổi chỉ việc dựa qua.
Đấy dựa thì thịt tổ nhạc thúc và trung tâm tích trường lòng xấu,
khiến như trở tạm hàng gản tình và thàn trường ngày thuốc mấy thi,
và tổ chức hàng gản buổi khám,
tư đánh su khỏe trong vệ dân trẻ khắp bà của.
Đúng nhất, chỉ tính sinh trong lòng ngày nhỉ khu chăm ha mi tư.
Hẹt thống nhà thuốc và trung tâm tình trung lòng xấu đã tổ chức hơn mùng 1,5 trung trình đồng hành tí cực động.
Tật trung tâm xóc bệnh li mạ tình, kết hợp với hơn 2,5 tình lấn và cường đẹ học ít dự chính bà của.
Bởi tầm mình phát triển vinh vấn cũng cảm kết thành đồng tí cực động.
Lòng xấu sẽ tức tục hợp tắc cho chế cũng có lần bị ý tế với tiến trình hai dự án và mở giống cuối mô với nhiều hạt động tí tự khó nối.